I guess if you have an addiction in life
it's nice to have one like curiosity I
am NOT going to figure out where to
drive the bus until I've got the right
people on the bus
not only that 15 of the 18 built to last
companies lived through the 1930s
depression I can remain focused on and
suffer for the big thing longer than
anyone else and I'm about to fall
I'm 400 feet above the ground please
turn off your electronic gadget but what
was Intel known for Intel delivers see
if you have the right people there
already motivated the question is not
risk or not risk the question is where
do you place your big bets I'm
genetically encoded to do it when I do
it I feel like a fish in water he's an
American business consultant author and
lecturer he's a student and a teacher of
leadership he's authored or co-authored
six books that have sold over 10 million
copies worldwide he's Jim Collins and
here are his top 10 rules for success I
guess if you have an addiction in life
it's nice to have one like curiosity yes
I mean questions for me or where
everything begins and I always like to
describe it that I don't pick questions
in many ways they pick me they kind of
rise up and grab around the throat and
say I'm not going to let go and to me
life is just a journey of question upon
question and there's so many chances to
learn things one of my mentors john
gardner who was in the johnson
administration was a senior faculty at
stanford wrote about excellence I wrote
about excellence truly before people
were thinking about it and renewal and
self renewal and John had this wonderful
way of saying I don't don't don't try to
be interesting be interested and and
that stuck with me and and this idea of
always be interested and you never know
what a question will go you sit down
with somebody and you ask a simple
question like where are you from okay so
think about the power of that question
where are you from that's not a
hierarchical question that's not a
question of
what do you do or how important are you
its where are you from and somebody can
choose it's an invitation well I'm from
Virginia or I'm from Greece or I'm from
they can name their company they can
choose and the interesting thing is you
never know where that will go
and then in actual work it all has to
begin with questions because if you
actually know the answers then I don't
understand the point of doing the work
when dick Cooley became chief executive
of Wells Fargo in the late 1970s he knew
he would be facing the storm of
deregulation he knew that the entire
banking industry would be upended when
deregulation swept through the board
understandably concerned asked Cooley
what is your vision what is your
strategy where will you lead us how will
you get us through the storm of
deregulation and Cooley had a wonderful
answer I don't know not only that it's
the wrong question see I am NOT going to
first figure out where to drive this bus
and then get people on the bus know I'm
going to do it completely opposite I am
NOT going to figure out where to drive
the bus until I've got the right people
on the bus and only once I've got the
right people on the bus the wrong people
off the bus and the right people on the
key seats then and only then will I turn
my attention to the question of where we
will drive this bus the best executives
we've studied always think first about
who and then about what it's not about
just getting a great team it's not about
finding talent it's not about getting
great people no the key word is first
first get right people first get the
people on the bus first think about who
put who of the head of strategy who a
head of tactics who a head of technology
who a hit of business ideas who a head
of everything
first who first who first who then what
I mentioned earlier the work built to
last is very interestingly
during great companies in contrast to
others went back recently and realized
we selected the study set for that study
in 1989 two decades ago all 18 of the
built to last companies are still
standalone independent and almost all of
them very successful companies today if
you took a random sample of large
publicly traded companies 20 years ago
what are the probabilities that all
eighteen in your random sample would be
standalone independent and largely
successful today the number is less that
the percentage is about 0.02 percent
probability not only that 15 of the 18
built to last companies lived through
the 1930s depression what do they teach
us what has enabled them to have that
what did we find that separated them and
what we found is that what really
separated was not necessarily that they
had smarter strategies although they
often did or that they were sort of more
financially savvy although they often
were it was because they were founded
first and foremost and built always on a
rock-solid set of core values that are
not open for negotiation and if you look
at what gave them the reason to struggle
the reason to fight the reason to endure
it wasn't strategic it was values one of
the greatest probably the greatest rock
climber of his generation as you know
I've been a climber most of my life is
actually right now on site of El Capitan
doing what will probably be the hardest
rock climb certainly ever done in our
lifetimes trying to free climb anything
called the dawn wall on Mescalero side
of El Cap young man named Tommy Caldwell
who is using a category of one and I was
out climbing with Tommy one day and I
said to him Tommy what makes you
different here's a record of six climbs
on El Cap that have never been repeated
okay he's just he is 10x in extreme
environments and he's still alive I said
tell me what is it that you have you're
not necessarily
physically gifted you're not necessarily
stronger right here certainly physically
gifted all those things but you're not
this incredible athlete that that just
it was born this way and in fact he had
lost a finger in an accident he cut a
finger off and so he's doing this - one
of his important things be an important
finger and he thought about it for a
long moment he said I can remain focused
on and suffer for the big thing longer
than anyone else and I think that's what
did you obey the curiosity keeps me one
but once they get their hands on what
they see is the thing they don't let go
and they can stay with it and suffer for
it when I was in high school I must have
been maybe 16 or 17 years old and I went
rock climbing in El Dorado Canyon where
I near where I grew up in Boulder I've
been climbing about 3 or 4 years and I
went to do a climb called t2 now the
time t2 was a relatively difficult climb
and I went at it with a kind of an
arrogant lack of preparation and I
hadn't prepared for being able to do
certain kinds of finger cracks I figured
I'll figure it out when I get there and
I also didn't pause this is I think
about boldness and discipline I didn't
pause to really double smack
double-check all my systems okay so I'm
on the fourth pitch I'm about 400 feet
above the ground I'm going across this
slanting crack system that I'd had
trouble that I started after whether my
forearms started to engorge with blood
and lactic acid which means at some
point even if you're on a big hold your
hands are going to melt off okay and I'm
about to fall I'm 400 feet above the
ground but it should be okay because
there's protection
I'm tied into the rope I may take a fall
but I'll get caught for some reason and
to this day I still don't know why my
brain triggered that I should look at my
knot and I looked down at my knot
my not had come untied I had made the
mistake of jive never really thinking
about the best nut for certain types of
situations and I tied him with what's a
bowline now the advantage of a bowline
is it's easy to untie if you write the
disadvantage of a Boldin is it's easy to
untie it had come untied as I kept
moving across and it is just hanging in
my harness I'm seconds away from falling
only now I will die I will die if I fall
off my forearms are melting and the knot
had come untied and so I called down to
my partner I said why not come on time
what is he going to do he can't do
anything you just watch me fall to my
death and I there was an old fixed Pete
up in the rock that we put there from
the first ascent an old soft iron Pete
on and I looked at it and I probably had
15-20 seconds before my hands went
unwrapped if that maybe 10
I took a runner and I clipped it into
the Piton I clipped the Pete on into my
heart of the runner into my harness and
just went please hold
and I let go and it helped I put in a
backup I grabbed the not be tied it went
to the legend convulsion I can't I was
very calm at that moment I got to the
ledge I went into convulsive shaking I
was sick to my stomach for days because
of the the whatever happens chemically
what I learned from that is two things
the first is that when you're in an
unforgiving world gravity is unforgiving
it doesn't care it never takes a day off
ever and if you make one mistake it can
kill you if it's the wrong kind of
mistake and what I learned is that sense
of yeah I want to do adventurous things
I want to climb rocks I want to be in
Yosemite I want to do things that get my
adrenaline going I but I need the
discipline to always do all the right
preparation to always think about the
right nuts to always be cross-checking
my system so that I can do those bold
things and stay alive in an unforgiving
environment and as you and I spoke about
earlier too
I think that's the rest I think we are
all heading into an unforgiving
environment where we're going to have to
be both bold and disciplined the second
thing I learned what if that Piton had
not been there we might not be here
together it was just by chance that that
Pete Tom was right there and once you
realize when you rewind the tape of your
own life is that there are these crucial
moments where if the luck had gone the
other way you might have gotten killed
and so what you have to do is to always
be X putting those extra disciplines in
place because I was lucky to live and
what I took from that is I never want to
have to be lucky to live again I want to
live because of my discipline not
because of my luck please turn off your
electronic gadget
not for others but for yourself
effective people take time to think
begin the discipline of putting white
space on your calendar where there's no
phone no no email I was going to say no
fax but they don't even have that
anymore
no Twitter no emails no connections and
engage in this glorious pockets of
quietude to think juno that rick warden
reads a book every single day a book a
day a book a day 365 days a year
you're at a thousand books in three
years first innovation is extremely
important I would would not want to send
any indication we should stop innovating
in America shouldn't innovate a the V&A
about damn well understand what made us
innovative and make sure we don't lose
those things exactly right we don't I
can't afford to lose those things what
we found is that any given industry has
a threshold level of innovation and that
once you get to that you have to get to
that threshold for something like
Airlines it's relatively low and for
something like biotech it's really high
and but that once you meet that
threshold of innovation it's not
innovation alone that makes you
exceptional it is actually the blend of
being able to put the innovation plus
the organizational discipline again we
go back to as Apple just an innovation
story know at some point it was a whole
bunch of other things around it that
made it work if we go back we look at
Intel what was Intel known for well yes
it had a lot of innovation because to be
in semiconductor industry you had to
have a lot of innovation but what are
they always the most innovative no and
at critical junctures they might even
bit a little bit behind but what was
Intel known for Intel delivers so you
are IBM what's your worst nightmare you
don't have enough chips at affordable
cost when the time comes and you can
look at different comes you got maybe
one chip that's more innovative but
you've got another chip that's
innovative enough but it's got the
organization behind it with the
discipline and it delivers where you
gonna Pat it delivers it delivers
exactly right I've always loved the
story silver blaze which is the shore
back home story where at the end of the
case the constable asked Holmes what was
the key to the case and Holmes says it
was the Curious Incident of the dog in
the night-time and the constable says
but the dog didn't do anything in the
nighttime ah-ah
yes that was the Curious Incident the
dog didn't bark and so therefore I knew
the criminal must have been somebody who
knew the dog in our research it is the
dogs that do not bark that often give us
some of the best clues and there the
dogs that do not bark helped us see the
who principle now you would think that
if you're leading a company from good to
great one of the things you would expect
to see one of the dogs you would expect
to bark is that you would find very
motivating and charismatic leaders who
could infuse motivation into the troops
so that they would go out and do good to
great things well as our researcher
unfolded what we found is that most of
the good to great leaders had had a
charisma bypass they couldn't motivate
anybody that's just a pure motivational
force that's not how they led but then
when we began asking them how did you
get alignment how did you get people
motivated behind what you were trying to
do the dog just didn't bark they didn't
spend any time on that that's not how
they went and we scratched our heads a
little bit how would you make sense of
the fact that you're getting a whole
company to go in a different direction
and yet the leaders who made this happen
didn't invest in figuring out how to
motivate people how to inspire people
how to get people behind the flywheel
and this is when we learn something see
if you have the right people
they're already motivated the right
people are self-motivated the right
people are self disciplined and the
challenge of management the challenge of
leadership is not to how to figure out
how to motivate the wrong people into
the right people it's how to get the
right people and then not do all the
stupid management things that tend to be
motivate the already motivated people
what you also talked about in your book
is is not to take big risks not to you
said fire cannonball yeah what you well
you want to fire cannonball so this is
the really interesting thing the the
fire bullets them fire cannonballs it's
not a matter of the question is not risk
or not risk the question is where do you
place your big bets because if you don't
place a big bet then you're never
actually going to achieve exceptional
results and see if you're never really
going big the question is how do you
place your big bets and bound your risk
at the same time and there the answer is
what we found is that all of our
companies and all of our leaders did
place big bets but they placed them
after they had proven that they'd taken
most of the risk out by proving that
that bet would likely pay off the
uncalibrated cannonball is dangerous the
calibrated cannonball is how you get
something great if you think about sort
of how people apply themselves when we
go back when we look at the good to
great data and some of the other data we
find that that there's these three
circles and you put your energies in the
middle of three circles and the first
circle is what you're passionate about
and what you love to do and what you
stand for and the second circle is what
you can be the best at and the third
circle is what drives your economic
engine ok now then you focus your
energies there but let's drop that down
a level to the individual how many of
the folks under age thirty in here have
had cross your mind
the thought I wonder what I'm going to
do with myself ok I'd like to you to
think then about finding your own three
circles at an individual level which is
think about it this way imagine that you
could engage your energies and your time
directly in the middle of three tests
first it is something for which you have
great passion that you love to do and
that absolutely reflects your values and
when you wake up in the morning there's
the sense of my goodness even if I'm
getting paid for this I would want to do
it even if I wasn't getting paid for it
now imagine if in addition to that you
could marry it to a second circle which
is finding what your genetically encoded
for and there's a big difference of what
you're good at and what you're
genetically encoded for I discovered
this as a young person I went off to
college I thought I would be a
mathematician I had done well on math
tests but when I entered courses like
real analysis I met those who were
genetically encoded for math
not being one of them I needed to find
another version of my three circles and
now imagine the third circle as you're
engaged in something that makes that is
of great value it's of either social or
economic or both of value it makes a
contribution you are useful now imagine
you have all three man I'm passionate
about this I love to do it expresses my
values I'm genetically encoded to do it
when I do it I feel like a fish in water
and then finally third I'm useful and
what percentage of the world do you
think has that 5% maybe not even what
would happen to the world if let's say
it's 3% if we then made it 20% of people
who are doing what they're passionate
about genetically encoded for and are
useful are in positions of real
contribution and value now I don't know
the answer of how we make that
percentage go up the linking back to the
idea of Maslow how did he describe
self-actualization it wasn't hanging out
on the beach
he defined self-actualization as
discovering what you were meant to do
and committing to the ardour of pursuing
it with excellence the purpose of free
society I would suggest is to
systematically increase the percentage
of people who do exactly that
and then they can do it for very long
periods of time thank you so much for
watching we made this video because our
nose ssj2 if there's anyone that you
would like us to feature please leave a
comment below we'd also love to know
what your gym collins top ten rules
meant the most to you leave it in the
comments below and we'll join the
discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and we'll see you soon